sol quente tudo pequenininho segurando a
bolsinha aqui e eles vão em grupo e o
grupo é a mesma pessoa que brigaram na
sala de aula meia hora atrás e o plano é
tocar a campainha e todo mundo sair
correndo isso só pode não dar certo por
dois fatores primeiro fator se tiver
cachorro cachorro tem ódio de menina ela
tá preparado aqui para tocar a
campanhando cara vai triscar o dedo
[__] desgraça aí o plano falha e a
número dois é o seguinte a gente para
antes de chegar na casa olha para todo
mundo e combina um toca e todo mundo
corre aí o cara vai lá tá todo mundo
preparado pensa que não toca na
campainha e sai correndo dá uns quatro
passa Olha pra trás tem um fela da [__]
andando bem devagarzinho dizendo assim
se perguntar quem foi eu digo já dá
infância Teus amigos te traindo né todo
mundo corre entra na primeira esquina
que tem na hora que acaba passa tu é
doido nós tinha combinado para todo
mundo correr rapaz você sabe que eu não
gosto dessas coisas esse negócio de
ficar tocando campanha e sai correndo
cara sempre que o cabra tinha combinado
tinha aceitado não gosta dessa qualquer
filha da [__] eu fiquei de trair o
movimento aí ó otário aí vai os cara
rodar de novo